[Music]
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] come here okay all right
then go ahead be that way
damn jumping up on me and biting me and
[ __ ] trying to
she wants me to to wrestle well yeah she
wants me
now she look at her she rolled on her
back
trying to tell me to come down there and
wrestle with it come down here and
i can't wrestle see look at her [ __ ] i
can't wrestle
she's calling me down she's back there
like yeah
trying to calm me down come on what's up
she was attract she was trying to eat my
lipstick this morning because one thing
she likes to do is she likes to when i'm
sitting in front of my makeup mirror put
my makeup on in the morning
she likes to park herself right in front
of the makeup mirror and just sit there
and be like pet
me please and she sits there like a
little loaf and then she tries to eat
every single like
brush every single this morning she
actually stole my lipstick for a little
while she took it she got it in her
mouth and then like she jumped off the
bathroom counter
but then she dropped it and then she was
like nah [ __ ] it too much trouble
yeah okay gonna have uh an announcement
our friend sophie good friend of mine
and she's been over here uh once uh she
still wants to
she wants to come back and visit again
and go on the show as a guest yeah
but they're [ __ ] one sure her
family's [ __ ] with her about flying
during a pandemic and all that [ __ ]
anyway she sent me
she supposedly this is a bootleg of the
mat whole mandalorian series on blue
blue look it's all like i can't tell
that that's a boot red boot
that looks factory but look what you can
do with technology
nowadays she said that she told me it
was a bootleg
yeah or at least she thought it was a
bootleg that looks factory to me look
it does yeah i saw it i'm excited i
don't know how
i'm excited i don't know how they did
that if that's bootleg
ken says uh saw episode 100 last night
awesome shogun warriors
that's right like our 100 show it was
like oh yeah
remember back in the old days when we
did like when we got to our 100th
episode and we're like we're gonna make
this an extra long episode and i think
it was like three hours ago and now we
do like [ __ ] five
hours get drunk and this shit's five
hours long
so right some of the people some of the
people who are listening are [ __ ]
like long
haul truckers and [ __ ] so you know
they're like [ __ ] listening to the
whole show and everything
just you know a lot some people are
working when they're listening so
they love it when it goes along yeah it
makes their day work day go by faster
it's just fun it's funny to me to think
back on it when i was like
trying to keep the show under an hour
all the time like how the hell did i
even do that
and then sometimes i felt like i didn't
have enough material just even for an
hour and it's like now
we can do an hour without even like
getting to the top
just like farting around and like
talking about random [ __ ]
yeah says kk will be after you now tom
who's kk
i don't know who kkk is i don't know the
clan
i knew who the kkk is kkk is kkk it's a
baby
zach says literally listening to y'all's
show while watering plants at lowe's
okay that sounds kind of nice what
format are you listening on zach you
listening on
on uh like podcast
or what because we have a podcast audio
only version i don't we don't know how
many people are on it
yeah i just i uploaded to like some
[ __ ] thing and it supposedly goes to
itunes and all that other kind of stuff
i've been having trouble like the last i
think um the same [ __ ] happened with the
florida legends show that we the live
stream that we did on saturday
it's like it seems like the whole video
is coming up but when i try to download
the audio i only get two hours
so i'm gonna have to wait probably
another day for it to like process out
i heard i heard that on one of the on
[Laughter]
one of the reviews for one of the
podcast formats that we have there's
some chick jumped on there
talking about how evil i was how i was a
[ __ ] retro
[ __ ] misogynist sexist homophobe
racist
because of [ __ ] my lack of social
distancing and
sophie jumped on there and told her to
told her to [ __ ] off sorry as far as i
know but
because they they talk about us on the
on um
the podcast reviews evidently yeah which
we're not really aware of we don't even
look at it we don't even look at that
[ __ ] because it's so it's kind of funny
if you got anything to say to us go on
[ __ ] facebook and say some [ __ ] not
facebook but [ __ ]
facebook or [ __ ] youtube we'll just
block you
i mean well that's what i mean it's like
like i said if somebody makes like a
[ __ ] up comment on youtube i just
just block them i don't have
those kind of feelings you know i don't
give a [ __ ]
i just think it's funny you know
anything that's an advertisement to come
watch the show well like i said i don't
think i don't really get why
um people would listen to something and
they don't like it and then would spend
like a lot
of time they list hateless complaining
about it we got two hate listeners at
least two hate listeners on [ __ ]
on youtube there's always two thumbs
down and they happen instantly
you know what though he gets kind of
like he's like what's all with all the
thumbs down dude the other day
i was watching a video yes this is what
happened
i was watching a video of like an
adorable cat that looked like a muppet
playing fetch and that had like 52 like
thumbs down
and i'm like really who is who is thumbs
downing an adorable cat playing fetch
come on now
i'm looking at the on air sign it's
different this time it looks good though
is it well i just got there are like 40
bajillion different effects on here i
have it over here on this other screen
yeah and um you can't really like a lot
of them are kind of similar because you
can't really see the color like on this
thing so
if you can see the color it looks really
neat but you can't really see it as good
and um so i'm trying to pick one that's
not as bright this one this one's called
bouncing balls
for some reason there's must be a way to
have the effect but then dim it because
if it dims you can see the color
you know what's weird is look there's a
brightness thing over here but i did
that and it didn't do anything it didn't
do anything
try it again you want you can try it
again yeah i
i bet you it i bet you did work all the
way down all the way down to nothing
yeah it doesn't no it did it's just a
lack it's oh okay
there's a lag so it works okay it works
today i guess i was too impatient you're
too impatient the way you are so that
it is i'm like you have to do it
immediately yeah
that's it right there i put it on a
pretty one i'm gonna call it
i don't have time for this kind of i
don't know it's part of the show what
are you talking about
chase rainbow yeah now ooh
now turn the brightness all the way
almost all the way down
so you can see so you can see the colors
give it a second
oh did it go down it's kind of cool yeah
like i said if you if you have it on too
bright then you can't read the words
turn it down
like some more dude that's like almost
all the way down yeah
there you go oh okay there we go so you
actually have to turn the brightness all
the way down you can actually
see the colors there you go see how good
that is yeah you see
this is the thing that i try this i'm
gonna tell the audience this this
regulars in in
in the comment section i'm a [ __ ]
genius
i'm a [ __ ] genius i'm
super super intelligent and she don't
[ __ ] listen to me
she doesn't i said turn that [ __ ] oh no
no no no no no turn it down it'll be
no just think i was doing it yesterday
and it wasn't it didn't look like it was
doing it because you're so [ __ ]
impatient look how beautiful that looks
okay that's [ __ ] beautiful and it was
my idea so
even more beautiful yeah but even if it
was my idea you'd say it was your idea
because that's how you do okay whatever
he steals my jokes he does all that
stuff all kind of [ __ ] like that well
i'm just like
well i'm just i'm just called
appropriation because it's
appropriate joke appropriate
appropriation yes sometimes not you know
a lot of my shit's original
well i'm i'm just showing you what it's
like because you don't ever listen to me
ever so look how
beautiful look at look at on the screen
look at that it's beautiful those colors
are
thank you thank you and that does that
look great guys that looks really good
well yeah now we can find because it's
barely lighting up
when you look at it in person called
chase rainbow when you look at it in
person it looks like it's
dark yeah it looks super dark that's
really good to see everybody's talking
about
let's see what everybody's talking about
[Laughter]
okay kathleen kennedy yeah yeah [ __ ]
kathleen kennedy they're gonna kick her
ass out
and [ __ ] disney disney ran itself into
the ground they wouldn't [ __ ] listen
they just wouldn't listen okay
we know all kinds of people that work at
disney and disney's an evil empire
in the future people will argue about
whether or not tom actually existed
just like the skunk gate
[Laughter]
the man the myth the legend yeah i am
looking forward to um
mandolin i'm looking forward to this
mandalorian series
yeah because that seems to have gotten
like pretty much universal game
i uh was i was telling sophie about the
original star trek series and she was
like real skeptical i don't know if i
like i don't know so oh
no that's just [ __ ] [ __ ] she's much
horny yeah
and and i said it's got a lot of the
same writers that the twilight zone had
she goes well i love that series the
original toys are like yes
now she's hooked on that [ __ ] she goes
this [ __ ] is really good she's like on
episode 7. like see we told you yeah i
told you
there there's a reason why the original
star trek
is a thing that why it's still like it's
culturally
relevant even to this day you go watch
the original star trek and you get blown
away
it is theatrical but that's the way
television
and and movies were in the 60s it's
everything was a
it was a [ __ ] show putting on a show
you know
we're putting on the show not a chef
which i like that i like that style
okay so what are we talking about today
what are we doing i am talking about the
movie that i watched last night
on to be like i said i'm watching all
the new horror movies on to be checking
them out
this was actually a pretty good one i
was like uh
pleasantly surprised because the thing
about it is that
so the title of it is mom mothers of
monsters
which is kind of a dumb title but this
is apparently the first
uh the debut directorial debut
of a director named tusia or tusha lyman
now this is um a psychological horror
film
and it's found footage kind of but it's
done
in a sort of it's not necessarily found
footage is in hey we found some footage
but
in a way that um this is someone that's
recording
[ __ ] like for posterity so it's all
coming from
um you know security cameras and you
know home
you know cameras that she installs in
the home and stuff like that so she can
like have proof of her assertions
so the premise of the movie
is you have this woman named abby she's
42.
and she is a single mom and she has a
son named jacob who is 16.
and she suspects that jacob
might be a psychopath and that he's
going
and that he's like planning to do
something like shoot up his school or do
something like that
and so as the story goes on it's mostly
just the two of them there are like some
other characters um ed asner has a
uh cameo actually i don't even know that
dude is still alive yeah i didn't either
actually
he looked like he was kind of still
alive
i was like is that it asner i like it
yeah you're like
damn yeah he's old as [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but
he's still kicking and he's in this
movie
okay uh he yeah he has a cameo as like a
psychologist or something that she talks
to over skype or zoom or whatever
and um so this is a really intriguing
story so that mostly
it's mostly told through
her thinking the sun is a psychopath no
one really
believing her or not or not believing
that it's as bad as she is
you know making it out to be so she's
decided that she's going to
essentially spy on him um
to kind of prove that she's right about
how about how psychopathic he is
so she kind of installs cameras around
the house
and various other things now the way
that this is set up
it's really intriguing how this is done
because you think
that it's kind of all from her point of
view and the sun
to be fair does kind of seem like a dick
like he does do stuff that's like
psychopathic in nature but the
interesting intriguing thing about the
movie
is that you're not real sure whether
he is an actual psychopath maybe he or
maybe he's just kind of like just a dick
like a
teenager just a little bit more dickish
than usual or whether
she's projecting [ __ ] onto him or maybe
she's crazy
because there's a thing alike from her
past like her brother
um kind of went nuts and like shot up a
bunch of people
it when he was 16. so you think well
maybe
she's you know she's got mental problems
too and maybe she's projecting that onto
the kid
maybe it's like this crazy like feedback
loop where it's like he wouldn't have
been a psychopath
but the way she treats him like he's a
psychopath you know is maybe making him
act out in that way
because they do kind of show um him
acting in a way that's like
compassionate or empathetic um you know
but then it's kind of like
juxtaposed with like this [ __ ] you
know him like dropping a brick off a
[ __ ] overpass or like killing his pet
rats and
doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] but then he does
like nice [ __ ] too and he acts like kind
of nice around his friends and [ __ ]
so i like that they kind of played with
this
ambiguous is he a psychopath
is she a psychopath are they both
psychopaths is she
just reading into something what she
wants to read does she hate the kid
um and that's what's making him act that
way because he's almost like throwing it
back in her face
you know so you don't really um
get much of like a resolution about why
but it's like i thought it was like
really really well done
because the way that you know you kind
of get this unreliable narrator thing
going on with her
and then there's a point too where jacob
who's kind of like a
he he's like real intelligent you know
he's like real uh gifted and stuff
and so he kind of like figures out how
to like hack into her cameras and so
you're not really sure like
who you're seeing like watching the
videos you know i mean because he's been
able to like hack in and like watch kind
of her [ __ ]
and control some of the [ __ ] and then
like at the end it just goes like
batshit crazy like all kinds of
terrorism
you all have noticed that i haven't
really said much about it okay usually
that means i didn't like it
um i didn't really like this movie it's
not a bad movie though it's a good movie
i didn't like it because it's just not
the kind of movie that i like
it's this is a movie of the genre okay
the found footage type yeah
i really don't some people really like
that if you like that then you'd
probably like this movie
um for me the movie is dialogue driven
it's not very visual so i just don't
really like
that kind of movie um but i'm going to
give it credit where credits
do the you know the acting and story
were pretty good yeah i thought the
acting was really good because honestly
you really had to have um you know the
woman that plays
uh abby melinda page hamilton and uh the
kid that plays the son bailey edwards i
think is an
actor's name um the two of them had to
pretty much carry the whole movie on
their shoulders pretty much it's all
about them there's other people in the
movie too but not really
it's the whole heart of the movie is
like the relationship between this kind
of like really sick
relationship between the mother and son
and trying to figure
out who is the psychopath in the
situation or are they both a psychopath
and it's just i just thought it was a
really interesting i'm not a big fan of
found footage either but in this case i
think it was a good way to tell the
story
um because there was a legit reason for
it to be
found footage this is the best way to
tell the story
in on film yeah okay actually i think
this movie would be
or this story would be much better live
on stage
it would this would make a good play
yeah it probably would actually yeah
with good
scene settings and [ __ ] like that if you
did if you did the blocking right
it'd probably be a badass play yeah
because it's a character study largely
right but you know for film
you can make a low-budget movie that's
entertaining and there that a lot of
people would see
if this if it's on film so that's why
they went this way you could do it live
on stage it'd probably be a better
experience to see it live um but not as
many people would see it you know i mean
people don't go to theater
too much anymore you know not the
general audience that's a special
specialized thing
so i just understand it for what it is
me
personally when it comes to movies i
like [ __ ] that's real visual bunch of
stunts
explosions explosions explosions
[Laughter]
or you know real intense colors you know
like [ __ ] italian oldest italian
movies the way they look you know i like
i like a lot more of a visual thing this
this movie's not very visual it looks
like it was filmed with just like a
you know online footage found footage
yeah
that's what it was like camera you know
phones and laptops and [ __ ] you know
what i mean
but that's that's the genre yeah and
like i said i'm not a huge fan
you know and i don't like to say oh i
don't like this genre of movie because
you can always do something good
with whatever genre that you're working
in so i don't want to say like
categorically that i don't like found
footage but i don't usually
seek it out yeah it's kind of played out
well because
well one you know it's played out
because it's easy to do
but two i think the problem with you
know
a lot of found footage movies kind of
like you know especially kind of just
like throw away
uh you know low budget kind of ones is
that
you're kind of you're kind of taken out
of the realism of it because there's
you know why would you film that type of
thing
you know what i mean but i think this
one used that really well
because there was a reason this woman
was like look i'm
i'm not crazy my son is a psychopath and
i'm going to film him
you know because she'd set up secret
cameras all over just to catch his
behavior because no one was really
believing her
so and she wanted to upload it like to
help out other
mothers that's why it's called mothers
of monsters it's like you know let's
look for patterns you know what
you know how do we know if our kids are
bad you know so she was gonna like
compile all of this
and kind of like put it all together and
show it to other people and being like
see
i'm not like he is a psychopath so there
was like actually a reason for her to be
filming it it wasn't just kind of like
hey there's a murderer
coming after but let me make sure i film
that while he's coming to get me which i
do feel like a lot of found footage
that kind of [ __ ] for me for me the
problem with the found footage is the
tone
they're all totally the same so they all
kind of for me they end up kind of feel
generic
yeah they all feel so much alike it's
kind of like what kind of like i've seen
this movie before already
yeah because there were there are so
many of them that's the problem
i mean it's easy to do in any way i
think i prefer if you're gonna go
like you know in the general found
footage area i think i prefer
mockumentaries yes yes um you know what
i mean like
troll hunter or lake mungo which if you
guys haven't seen that that is
an amazing really really creepy
mockumentary yeah and the thing with the
mockup
that's also a good one the thing with
the mockumentary in terms of tonal
stuff that you can do with it there's a
lot of opportunity for [ __ ] humor
yeah in in a mockumentary you know not
only horror but humor simultaneously
because it's kind of like
they're making a documentary about
[ __ ] a troll hunter you know it's
just there's
some [ __ ] like that you know man you
start laughing about it
and it's taking itself seriously you
know you know that goes all the way back
to spinal tap
yeah you know it does all that spinal
tap so yeah i mean if i'm gonna say like
found like i've liked some
found footage movies now you know don't
get me wrong and i think this is a good
one this was a good utilization of
damn i know whole house shook florida
[Laughter]
florida afternoons in the summer it's
coming it is yes
jesus christ talk about thunder i know
but yeah so if you know if i'm going to
look at it at a found footage maybe i'm
going to watch a film footage movie
usually it's mockumentary like i said if
you haven't seen lake mungo
and you like mockumentaries then see
that because
that was one of the creepiest ones i've
ever seen and that one was really good
because
it was it was played completely straight
and everyone that was in it
seemed like a real person you know what
i mean so
you almost kind of had to check it's
like is this a real documentary because
it did
come across like that and then it was it
was like super super creepy like there
was like kind of supernatural [ __ ] in it
but
not to the extent that you didn't
believe it you know what i'm saying
so i thought that was really uh well
done as well but you know
like i said for uh for a debut feature
for a found footage movie um i think
this is really good
if you like psychological horror if you
like stuff like
um let's talk about kevin uh
you know it's that kind of thing it's
not as depressing as that because that
was like depressing as [ __ ]
um this one wasn't that bad i mean
in the sense that you wanted to kill
yourself after you watched it but
it's along the similar kind of lines of
like
uh you know my kid is a psychopath and i
don't know what to do about it and then
i might also have mental problems too
so i don't know i i thought it was good
and like i said it's on to be
uh for free if you want to watch it it's
not like it cost you anything yeah so
you know
and i think it's on amazon prime too if
you'd rather rather watch this a lot of
good [ __ ] on tubie for free
there really is like i said i've been i
i've been in there watching all the riff
track [ __ ]
i watched all the um all the live shows
they did with all the shorts
yeah because i [ __ ] love those shorts
then they find like the [ __ ] craziest
show
now somebody in the uh somebody in the
comment section was mentioning that
maybe we need to do some shirts with
like a twilight zone or a night gallery
theme that'd be a good book oh that is a
good idea good idea so they were seeing
like a mismatch between
twilight zone and and [ __ ] nightgown
i'm saying that again
i'm thinking that if you're gonna do
that do a different shirt for each one
we'll do like a twilight zone shirt
and then like a night gallery shirt yeah
we could even do
well and we could even do like the we
could put it at 13 o'clock like even in
that font because i think i have
that font somewhere right you know we
can we give that out as a prize or
you know i think that's a copyright
strike
violation you can't sell that but we can
give that away
yeah well i mean you could do
uh say a twilight zone shirt that said
13 o'clock in the twilight zone font
with maybe like a window or something on
it you could do that
i think i would go for a twilight zone
shirt and then just have 13 o'clock
like on the back like we normally did
yeah i guess we could do that
that because i just think that it looks
better if it's [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know we'll just
have to see and the thing about and
night gallery
i feel like night gallery didn't really
have a distinctive i mean the twilight
zone had that distinctive
lettering and like um you know that kind
of window motif
i feel like night gallery didn't didn't
have a real
like uh memorable logo you'd have to
invent one
you probably would it would look cool
though man yeah
i [ __ ] love night gallery now that i
wonder is that on toby
i watched it on hulu but that was a long
time ago when hulu still had free [ __ ]
which they don't anymore now it's all a
pay service
but um yeah cause i we have a canon film
one
coming don't we yeah i made a canon film
and what was that other studio that did
[ __ ] uh low budget cool
flicks gorilla cocarillo was that
[ __ ]
what are you talking about there was
another there was another studio that
was kind of
i think was cocarillo i think or carillo
films
it's kind of like that maybe i'm
thinking of canon
i don't know i had it had a logo similar
to canon films but they did like i think
cheap action flicks
maybe somebody maybe maybe i'm wrong
something that somebody might know in
the comments section all i could think
of was like that c
thing like that like coleco vision or
something like that that was like a
video game or a computer
maybe maybe i'm totally tripping the
black door from 2001 a good found
footage i'll have to look that up i
don't think i've ever seen it
yeah yeah that's it corolla co how do
you say it
coral co yeah yeah corolla that that's
who it was
was it two l's or one l what else they i
think they did action movies right
they had a cool logo yeah it's kind of
like canon caroleco or something
caroleco
right yeah that sounds kind of familiar
yeah but it had a really cool looking
logo
well now i'm gonna have to that was like
some [ __ ] that [ __ ] uh
uh you know like uh like in
you know death match or death sport or
some [ __ ] like that you know [ __ ]
what's his name [ __ ] [ __ ] chocolate
chocolate
damn movies [ __ ] yeah bloodsport you
mean bloodsports
yeah yeah i thought you meant it's like
wow bloodsport was already kind of like
a be great action movie and then they
made like another knock off of it called
death sport death sport and [ __ ] they
did have a death blood spurt
i think had david carradine in it didn't
it
he that [ __ ] was in everything man yeah
and they were riding around riding
around on motorcycles [ __ ] futuristic
motorcycles in the desert like
motorcycles like a fly and [ __ ] yeah i
think it was called death sport
it's like a futuristic post-apocalyptic
motorcycle fight to the dead or
something makes
[ __ ] man yeah there's so many bad ones
that's what i mean well they all had
names like that so it's like i can't
really remember
what the [ __ ] that was some [ __ ] back in
the 80s we used to just rent from the
[ __ ] video
well yeah 7 11 7
11 rented videos they did because we had
a 7-eleven next to my grandmother's
house and you went over there and it had
got some [ __ ] and all the tapes were
behind the counter yeah
so you couldn't steal them it just had
like a little card with the title on it
you had to pull the little card out and
take it over there and they had to give
it to you
be over my buddy yeah my buddies
he lived right he worked at 7-eleven to
live right behind it when he was a
teenager he used to
man he used to [ __ ] do all kinds of
cool [ __ ] like take a case of beer
and throw it away and then after work
would go over there and get it out of
the dumpster
see that's we were underage we were
under ages [ __ ]
we were like under ages we were embryos
yeah in fact he got caught he got caught
doing that [ __ ] but the manager was only
a few years older than us
yeah all right and he's like yeah he's
like yeah i understand man but look you
got to pay for that
so then we paid him
what kind of beer was it was it oh no it
was like [ __ ] schlitz miller
highlights
yeah it was like the worst like [ __ ]
like that here yeah we could steal it
and throw it out
all right but we had to pay for it yeah
that makes total sense
you know what i'm talking about that was
that was how we bought the [ __ ] under
the table
please tell me that one time you poured
beer into some slurpees
no we didn't do that no we were doing
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
vodka and slurpees before we did all
kinds of weird [ __ ] like we would
bribe a bum to go in all right
and get us some [ __ ] bunch of bunch
of bottles of mad dog 2020
wine and southern comfort and then we
would [ __ ] break the bum off we'd
[ __ ]
give him some of it well yeah you better
yeah we'd [ __ ] hook him up
and that was that was one of the things
we used to do we had we had a regular
bump that would go [ __ ]
this is our regular bomb so when i was
over in south gate
when the bomb wasn't on duty that day he
would get his replacement bombs
that bum was always hanging out in that
area
during that era during that era that bum
was always hanging out in that area well
because you guys were there giving him
like [ __ ] money and booze so
i know so why go somewhere else he's
like that's you know this is where my
bread is
right here i don't think it was just us
i think he was doing that for all the
[ __ ] kids and then
his job was the [ __ ] was was and i
guarantee the liquor store owner knew
exactly what was going on
that the bum had a [ __ ] backdoor
channel see he was the backdoor channel
to get the booze out to the [ __ ]
underage kids but we're talking about an
era in the [ __ ] mid to late 80s
nobody gave a [ __ ] not really the cops
didn't really give a [ __ ]
no they had bigger problems well the
drinking age had been
18 not too much and in some states it
was
like still 18 so
a lot of people didn't really go along
with this whole had to be 21 to drink
thing that's a new thing you know
used to be that you had to be 18 when i
was a little kid
to buy it yeah and but even it wasn't
even enforced then you had to be 18 but
16 17 that was sometimes close enough to
18. yeah because they didn't have any
ids anyway
yeah yeah they really didn't have ids
isn't it weird the first time i went to
the uk and this was in the 90s
they had driver's licenses but their
driver's licenses didn't have pictures
on them
and i just thought that was really funny
i'm like so you could basically just
theoretically you could use anybody's
driver's license they're like yeah i
guess so
whatever he said we would buy wine
coolers with food stamps that's what
[ __ ] louis said did you have
did you have thunderbird wine in the u.s
yes we did yes we did
mad dog and thunderbird and wild irish
rose
they had that too had all kind of and it
was like
it tasted like kool-aid yeah it was
super super artificial flavor but it's
all right you could definitely tell that
it was
like made for kids like i think and why
not
booze for kids foods for kids or wine
and yeah oh that's a new that's another
shirt
i'm gonna have a shirt with like a baby
bottle on it yeah it says booze for kids
and it claims to be wine but it wasn't
wine
i don't know what it was it wasn't wine
it was just probably some kind of
malt liquor or something maybe it was
wine
it's just kind of like you know you know
how some bars in orlando
like they didn't have a liquor license
like they could only sell wine and beer
but then
you could sell other types of like
liquor but it wasn't really liquor
yeah it was like malt liquor but it's
like made to taste
sort of like it's sort of like this
flavorless malt liquor that was
flavored yeah like hard liquid like hard
liquor yeah
and that's how they circumvented yeah
having a liquor license
the problem was with it is this is like
[ __ ] four percent alcohol you could
drink an entire bottle of that [ __ ] and
not get [ __ ] drunk
which is like what's the point right
yeah i mean you might as well just
that's what put that club under he
didn't he didn't have a [ __ ] liquor
license he was trying to sell that [ __ ]
as liquor and [ __ ] people got sick of
that real
quick i mean he didn't deserve that
business anymore i don't mind it if it
was like a dollar
yeah but i'm not paying like for a real
drink if it's not
that particu that particular business
owner jumped into the [ __ ] club scene
thinking that it was the 80s
and the game had totally changed yeah
you have to have hard liquor
zach says i just googled wild irish rose
and found a website called bumwine.com
yeah [ __ ] right and 2020 was mad dog
yeah mad dog 2020. we had that too they
still sell that i think
yeah it's [ __ ] and they sell that [ __ ]
in a plastic bottle they don't even
having glass and glass yeah you just go
there right on the if you go in like
some of the sketchier convenience stores
which we have
recently like you know if you need
something yeah and uh you they're just
kind of on the end cap that's where you
go you get your 20 20 you get your
cigarillos or whatever you just buy your
blueberry flavored cigars yeah
like that you can just buy one at a time
like from the little plastic cup on the
counter
that's that's what you do man if you got
like some extra money you can get one of
those rolly hot dogs
and they sell that [ __ ] right next to
those little glass tubes with the
[ __ ] paper roses in there that's
right they're like oh well we don't know
what that shit's for yeah no the [ __ ]
crack pipe
yeah they're like no it has a rose it
rose in it no it's a [ __ ] crackpot
it's not for it's not yeah that's not
for smoking crack that's just for some
reason i was just
reminded of um of uh
dan bell's show another dirty room yeah
which
you guys if you've never seen that go
watch that [ __ ] because they stay in
like the sketchiest hotels like around
the country yeah
and uh i a few times i've been watching
that and just like gagged because it was
so [ __ ] gross
but it's like pretty much every room
that they stay in
they find drug paraphernalia somewhere
when when i was a kid when we were
[ __ ] when i was a kid and had to had
to [ __ ]
hire bums to get alcohol back in those
days
back in my day we had to hire hobos
[Laughter]
a bottle of mad dog or wild irish rose
was 99 cents
they probably still have nothing and it
was like a
shape like a flask kind of like a big
flask
so you could put it in your pocket in
your big loose pants underneath
your dick your bum pants yeah your bum
pants underneath your [ __ ]
so you can conceal it underneath your
[ __ ] bum robe
or your your jacket your what do they
call that [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
you're transcoding the trench coat yeah
and uh that [ __ ] was like 99 cents and
we'd buy like 10 of them
we'd be like [ __ ] the slashing and [ __ ]
but you'd have to drink 10 of them to
get any effect they weren't that strong
well yeah it wasn't until later we
realized that it's better just to
[ __ ] buy a fifth of [ __ ] scotch
get the good [ __ ] get the good shape all
your money together man
when you're stealing some money from
your mom's purse go get some good booze
when you're young you [ __ ] buy
alcohol based on what what it's called
it's name and what color it is
get that [ __ ] red mad dog to say
that's just strong
[ __ ] us up get that [ __ ] bright green
mad dog without i wonder though
sometimes that if you're a kid
and you drink and even though like the
alcohol volume is very very low
like the fact that you think it's going
to make you drunk is going to make you
act drunker than
you no it didn't work it didn't work so
we'd have to drink several bottles of
that before we
because when you're a kid your
metabolism is really [ __ ] good
yeah yeah it takes it takes you got a
good resistance
little [ __ ] monkeys i had real good
[ __ ] resistance i'd just be
you know drink a [ __ ] half a fifth
[ __ ] southern comfort and still be
standing
running around and still be basically
sober
and i couldn't do that now yeah i don't
know why i guess your
your metabolism can run real like
everything else when you get old
everything starts to suck
starts to affect you more or something
but now i can drink a lot of alcohol
back then and just remain
you're under the influence but you just
you don't feel it
yeah you know it's not like you're just
like yeah you have to drink a lot before
you [ __ ] slosh and you know what i
mean there was times where you know
some of that [ __ ] you know pounding
not knowing how to drink real alcohol
like not knowing how much
[ __ ] southern you know or how how
what am i sure what
what what was that it was shiva's regal
we were drinking not
knowing how much shiva's regal you can
really drink
yeah i mean not really knowing how
strong a drink is
we were drinking that [ __ ] on the rocks
and mixing it with coca-cola it must
drink [ __ ] half a fifth just in a
[ __ ] less than an hour
that's a lot of [ __ ] booze it is
especially for somebody weighs about 130
435 pounds you know what i mean and all
of a sudden it just hits you like a
[ __ ] tidal wave
of [ __ ] ass just like boom and you're
like
oh and you're running running through
the window and throwing up outside the
window and [ __ ]
hopefully no she's not going by outside
yeah and we were all getting sick you
know
all of us we were about 16. well that's
the thing too is that i think
too when you're younger you drink like a
[ __ ] ton because it doesn't affect you
but
and you're a kid you're drinking to
prove something you don't really realize
you don't understand what the dosing and
what the dose is
so yeah you're hitting it too hard and
too fast
and it just [ __ ] it just [ __ ] hits
you like a [ __ ] landslide
you gotta you gotta learn how to slow
down let the [ __ ] [ __ ] creep into
your system you know maybe
we didn't know that back then it's gotta
be you gotta learn it
you gotta learn it through trial and
error and then you wake up with a
[ __ ] bad hangover the next morning
and you're like oh
[ __ ] your head just going boom i'm never
doing that again then the next weekend
you do the exactly bad [ __ ]
man because you're a kid
[Laughter]
well no we did it again that's what i
just said
you say you're never going to do it
again and then you do it again just did
it we just did it more effectively
[Laughter]
yeah lasted a little bit longer yeah i
mean you're going to pay all that money
for booze you got to like kind of enjoy
it man i mean you want to get a buzz but
you don't want to be like so [ __ ] up
that sometimes [ __ ] we would steal
steal some that [ __ ] from our parents
from their [ __ ] private stats see you
guys were lucky because my parents
didn't really drink
not because they were weird or anything
they just it just wasn't something yeah
rich parents
so i didn't really uh when i was in
brazil anybody
when i was in brazil when i was in
brazil i went to a really
high-end private school called escola
graduated sao paulo you can look it up
online
that's where like the president of
brazil's kids go and [ __ ] all the
diplomats and
the [ __ ] heads of the brazilian
industry their kids all go there
[ __ ] armed guards and [ __ ] huge
walls around it
it's like an internal paradise and it's
[ __ ] weird you know
uh that's where the you know ebstein
level [ __ ] [ __ ] you know those guys
are
but the south american versions that's
why i'm so skeptical
because i know what they're like anyway
um
one of our friends in our little [ __ ]
crowd was the son
of the uh ambassador of south korea
he was one of our buddies and we would
go to his house to go drink
he's the ambassador ambassador from
south korea
he in his apartment was an entire floor
of one of the skyscrapers in downtown
sao paulo
his booze closet was a room the size of
this room
and it had a booze closet his booze
clock yeah because he was throwing
inspirations
he was throwing diplomatic events in
that house yeah all right so
it had shelves and it was a whole
[ __ ] stock a top-of-the-line booze
and that's where we [ __ ] got our
hands on that shivvus regal
and then there was another one that we
had that he had it's called shiva's
royale
that [ __ ] was even better i think that
was like royale with cheese
i think that was like a [ __ ] 50-year
scotch or something
she was [ __ ] maybe 20 years i don't
remember it's been a long time and he
just had
and we would just go in there and
[ __ ] uh get some good booze
and it got to be when we were in brazil
because he had all the really good
imported [ __ ]
we would just buy it from him oh okay
yeah his name was mike oh
oh his last name yeah mike oh mike man
we need this this and this we need
some money and [ __ ] the next day he'd
show up to school he'd have a whole
bunch of it with him
and shopping in your booze closet yeah
shopping in his dad's booth
well here's the weird thing you know you
could take booze to your own high school
in brazil because what were they going
to do yeah the tuition was [ __ ]
astronomically expensive and you're
[ __ ] people get away rich people get
away with all kinds of [ __ ] your dad
would be the head of industries and
[ __ ] you know political figures
inside brazil my dad can have you killed
those those teachers were terrified of
those kids
terrified of them because they're some
of them their parents were [ __ ]
basically brutal dictators from the
era of [ __ ] brazil's military
dictatorship era so they weren't going
to say [ __ ] to those kids
it'd be like [ __ ] with saddam
hussein's kids even though they weren't
as bad as saddam hussein
yeah not really but some of them were
but uh
yeah true dog says i'm 26 but i haven't
tasted alcohol
it's not for everybody and like you know
different kinds
i didn't really start drinking until a
little bit later too
because it's just like i said i didn't
really grow up with it and it wasn't in
my house
so yeah i don't know it's it's still fun
though i don't really like now that you
know i'm almost 50 now so it's like i
don't really like to drink like a [ __ ]
ton because then you kind of feel like
crap the next day but like i said if you
take three aspirin and water before you
go to sleep somebody just
mentioned cisco i forgot all about
[ __ ] cisco see i don't think i've
ever drank that cisco was like mad dog
but it came into smaller bottles when it
first appeared what do they still have
that yeah i'm sure they do
and it had a it had a higher end
advertising campaign kind of like
kind of like cisco was respectable it
wasn't respectable
it was it was some it was some [ __ ]
bum one
it was it was bump it was classy bomb
wine
for slightly classier balls yeah
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] how much oh my god
how [ __ ] awesome would it be if they
if their whole advertising campaign was
that
like classy classy bomb one that would
be hysterical
and then another one we used to [ __ ]
with is all the malt liquors
and [ __ ] yeah they came in huge
[ __ ] 40-ounce [ __ ] bottles
and they all had these [ __ ]
outrageous [ __ ] names
it was like you know for those of you
who are not here in the united states
american malt liquor is kind of like a
whites and beer or a german bison that's
thick
thicker beer sweeter um
very drinkable all right but very
unrespected it's real [ __ ]
shitty stuff okay cheap
but effective boone's farm yeah yeah
remember boone's farm i've drunk
bones farm man and they had [ __ ] you
guys might remember some of them i think
one of them was called uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] diamondback was one of them that
was a [ __ ]
diamondback mall everything had some
kind of animal on it
like a [ __ ] snake or a scorpion or a
scorpion or some [ __ ] like that
something that was like on purpose like
bad ass
used to like it though it was [ __ ]
tasted good it tasted good but if your
buddies saw that they saw you drinking
that like you're drinking that [ __ ]
you know some real babies yeah they want
no
you get some real beer you know then
they try to give you a heineken which is
[ __ ] more [ __ ] honey can suck too
piss water german piss like i said i'm
not a big fan
i'm you know i'm more a hard liquor
person i'm not a big fan of beer
pretty much the only like kind of normal
beer that i
can actually drink enough of to get
buzzed on is uh
[ __ ] what's that [ __ ] called that the
yingling yingling yeah like that one's
pretty good
yeah the black and tan is pretty good i
like micro brewed beers and craft beers
but you know i like coffee beers and uh
there's one place we used to go downtown
that had like a
vanilla stout that was i can't remember
what it was called but it was actually
pretty good most your american big
corporate beers are just some kind of
lager and it's [ __ ] cheap piss water
and americans love it because that's all
they know uh
well it's just kind of like if you're
out working in your yard in the summer
and you can drink it you don't want to
get too [ __ ] up
yeah i guess it's refreshing i don't
know i i was never a big fan
yeah don't make for you foreign people
don't make the mistake of thinking that
that stuff's real american beer it's not
real american beers craft type beers and
micro brewery beers that's
that's real beer the rest of that shit's
just corporate soft drink
piss water really yeah i mean we think
of it that way
yes and i'm not even a beer snob because
i don't even get garbage
it's just not good i wanna go ahead and
shut this down we've been on here too
long
yeah that's true all right so uh anyway
like i said if you like found footage
movies uh and psychological horror this
was a good one it's free on to be if you
wanna watch it but it's also on amazon
prime
he got it it was king cobra malt liquor
that's right
[Laughter]
cobra yeah
so uh we'll probably do another live
stream tomorrow either another movie
review or another sidetrack so we will
talk to you guys
again tomorrow bye